Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call. We're going to get started right away. A bunch of questions came in reminder to everybody that's new.
Always check the member site. I can't believe how many people we talk to on a weekly basis that have never been on the member site or never go on the member site. Obviously said you guys, because you're on the Zoom call, but I don't know.
I mean, it's included in your plan. So, I mean, is it opportunity for you to learn something? I don't know.
But all I know since it'll be on there, no, that you get a 5% subscription savings if you subscribe.
It's like a subscribe and save an Amazon to a supplements. If you need to order or to molecular if you can't find something on there or to molecular biotic and apex do not allow us to have the supplements visible online anymore. They don't allow anybody to in the companies that do or violating their principles and we don't want to violate their principles.
Also, and if you need an educational caller call with me, talk to me, please fill out the form online.
And when you do the cheek swab, please fill out a form online.
So the forms look like this right under the educational coaching call section on the member site homepage and other pages as well.
Remember, also you have access to all the courses that we have an access to all the blog posts. So if you're looking for something, there's almost 1000 blog posts.
You might find the answer there.
Can you tell me your thoughts on LDN, no dose, no truck zone, but it be combined with mistletoe.
So low dose, no truck zone is is an off label use of the drug, no truck zone, no truck zone that I think was 50 milligrams or people getting off of heavy drug drugs like morphine.
Now, truck zone is used to help get people off of drugs like morphine street drugs.
People that are addicted to drugs, but that's at 50 milligrams.
Someone I don't know who it was, I don't remember the story that found that using it in a low, low dose, starting at 1.5 milligrams, point up to 3 milligrams and then up to the maximum 4.5 milligrams, it's called low dose, no truck zone.
So they're using it off label. When you use a drug off label, you're using it for something that it wasn't technically approved of by the FDA.
So if it wasn't approved by the FDA for that, you're using it off label needed for some other thing.
Low dose, no truck zone has been used for autoimmune diseases because it tends to be an immune balancer or an immune regulator or what's called a T cell regulator.
It acts as stimulating what are called T rag cells.
So when a person is autoimmune and their immune system is flared against something with autoimmune, it's flared against self tissue.
Then low dose, no truck zone can call back down.
Now there's been some alternative doctors that have used low dose, no truck zone for cancer, which I don't, you don't know, to me, I struggle with understanding pathways with that because it really acts like the T regulator.
And you really want to stimulate the immune system. That's the whole idea of mistletoe therapy, mistletoe therapy is an immune irritant.
That's how it works as an immune irritant, it's firing a hyper immune response and then, you know, with that hyper T cell stimulation, you're going to possibly kill more cancer cells.
So I don't know why you would use low dose, no truck zone combined with mistletoe.
To me, it's kind of culture productive.
So I would ask the doctor, you know, if they're prescribing this, why they would prescribe it that way, I'm not quite sure that seems culture productive.
Do you think there would be positive results with my breast cancer with mistletoe for sure, that's possible.
But low dose, no truck cell, no, we have used, we've had people on low dose, no truck cell with auto immune disease, I haven't really recommended it.
Of course, I don't recommend it because it is a drug, but I haven't, I wouldn't really necessarily think it would be a good fit for cancer.
I know that there's some alternative cancer doctors that do use it.
Of course, that's not the only thing that they're using.
So I question whether that is really the thing that's helping the person, I don't know.
Do you think, what do you think of Ivermectin as a treatment and a tool for the prevention of COVID?
Well, I'm very much in favor of that and you can't argue with the benefit, the possible benefits of Ivermectin.
There's been multiple research articles for Ivermectin and cancer as well.
So Ivermectin is similar, but different than Mendezon, and it has both of those have been shown to help people with cancer.
Certainly, Ivermectin has been shown to help people with COVID, long haul COVID, and especially acute.
And preventative for COVID. So I think it's a great use.
Again, an off label, use of a drug.
Is there any other way to clean the eye and grow wave other than the periodic acid that was recommended by through life?
It is toxic and since we live in an apartment, there's no healthy way to use it.
Yeah, I understand that and I understand that that's a problem to be honest.
I would like to see a raise of hands of every one of our patients that uses the eye and grow wave on a regular basis and that actually do clean it.
I would suspect it's probably less than half the people.
We've had people that have used it and up to 80 times and have never cleaned it once.
The cleaning of it is probably more necessary for people with maybe dirty or water.
I haven't done any investigation on it. I don't know if people with chloride and fluoride in their water mainly I mean regular city water or build up.
I mean, it's actually more effective for a way of place or people that are using it with in a plural setting with a more harder water like for well water or something.
And it says I just rinse the hydro wave with salt water never use maryonic acid over a year.
more people fall into Ed's category too,
that they're not using the variotic acid.
But I do, we have had some people
that have had issues with their eye and pro-wave,
but I think it has to do with the hardest
to their water or something
because they had built up quite quickly on it.
I cleaned my monthly well water with a softer,
you go in an 18 months now.
Okay, so you cleaned it with variotic acid patty
where you clean it,
just with your well water rinsed it like it is.
Oh, with the acid, okay, okay.
So we'll come back to Mark's question.
Well, it's this ties to the low-dose del trexone.
That was me using the low-dose del trexone.
I started at 1 milligram February.
And as of today, I just went to three milligrams
back to the 4.5.
All the H is lower by a lot
and inflammation much lower with right.
So I would, I think the pathway there is
if the person has chronic inflammation
from some other source using low-dose del trexone
can call that down and that could possibly,
so going back to this question here again.
So if you're gonna use low-dose del trexone with mistletoe,
I would say spread them out.
If you're doing mistletoe injections every day,
then maybe at 12 hour point,
then use the low-dose del trexone.
Typically, low-dose del trexone is dosed
at night before you go to bed any house.
If you're doing mistletoe in the morning
to stimulate an immune response
and you're using the low-dose del trexone
to kind of clear out the inflammation at the end of the day,
then I guess it makes sense.
And I could see the efficacy of that,
especially if your cancer is tied to
some chronic inflammatory source in the beginning
that I could see that how you could tie that together
and you could make a case for that.
I'll be meeting with an endocrinologist
concerning a spot on my thyroid
that was shown to be cancerous three years ago
and now a new spot has been seen at a PET scan.
What are some questions or tests
that I can ask for with this doctor?
I want to avoid the removal of my thyroid.
Well, I would ask questions like how big is this spot?
Can we keep an eye on it and do another test in three months?
If they're solely going as a PET scan
or saying that this is another cancerous spot,
are they gonna plan on doing a biopsy?
What's the plan of attack with this?
Can you see the spot on ultrasound?
Can you see the spot on CT?
Can you see the spot on MRI?
How big is the tuberous area that they think is cancer?
All those kind of questions.
I would also run some tuber marker tests
to see if there's any other tests
that are gonna show, give you some objective data on
what's going on.
Again, just like anything else,
you don't ever want to just rely on one test
to make a life changing decision.
Hand Candida cause cancer.
Well, anything that can enter into your cell
and interrupt, affect the nucleus
and interrupt the replication cycle
can be a cause of cancer.
So, yes, I guess it can.
In our testing, have we seen that maybe a few times,
but if you have the rare side,
what herbs are IV treatment is good for Candida?
How would burberry be good for cancer?
Thank you.
So I pulled up the product label
or the Candisan forte,
which is the product that we use a lot with Candida.
That's a more than molecular product.
And just to show you what is in there
that has been shown through different studies
that can be helpful for Candida.
Burberry is one thing, this list
that can be very helpful for Candida.
What else is burberry and good for?
Well, burberry is really good
to lower your glucose levels.
So, somebody who has cancer
who's trying to keep a lower blood glucose level,
burberry is really good.
Somebody that has elevated glucose levels
due to pre-diabetes or diabetes type two diabetes,
using burberry can be really good.
What else is burberry and good for?
Burberry is the best killer for H. Pylori.
What's H. Pylori?
Is the number one got infection
that is 100% times occurrence
out of all the ulcerative intestinal ulcerations
like stomach ulcers and duandal ulcers.
100% of the time it's caused by H. Pylori overgrowth.
Also, about a fourth of the heart disease
and cordary artery disease issues are caused
by H. Pylori.
So, dealing with a chronic H. Pylori infection is important.
So, that's why I've told you
in these zoom calls over the years
that I take burberry not every day,
but I take it every month,
I'll take it for about a week
just because I have a history
and my family apart issues
and burberry is something
that's really good for that.
So, anybody that has a history of heart issues,
history of candida, history of gut infections,
parasitic infections, history of stomach ulcer,
or burberry is a good cancer killer
in a sense of that it can kill a cause of a cancer
if it's parasitic or bacterial related.
And secondly, it can help decrease blood glucose levels
which is always good for a cancer patient.
So, burberry is a really good for a lot of things.
It's one of my favorite supplements.
A regular leaf, paprika acid, cinnamon,
and other things on this list are good for candida.
I've been having some sleep issues lately.
I take the entourage.
So, the entourage for those who don't know it,
that's CBD. That's a CBD product.
It does not have any THC.
It's just CBD at night.
And this only helps for a couple of hours.
So, CBD, why would that help with sleeping?
Because it can really decrease inflammation in the brain.
And it can decrease glutamate in the brain.
So, that's why it can help with sleeping.
I tried in sonnetal, and that did not help either.
So, when sonnetal is a product for designs for health
that has melatonin in it and passion flower
and cannabelle and some other herbs that can be relaxing.
You have a melatonin that would that you would recommend.
I do.
I need to wait.
Or should I wait till another cheek swab any suggestions.
So, if the insomnetal didn't work at a higher dosage,
then just melatonin probably will be helpful for you.
So, whatever you have sleeping issues,
you do want to dig to whatever you have any issues.
You want to try to dig to why.
And it's not like you have a deficiency in, you know,
passion flower or wherever you have a deficiency in CBD
or something like that.
So, you, so what could be a cause of sleeping issues?
So, if you can't fall asleep, so what helps you fall asleep
is melatonin is the release of melatonin
by the paedial gland.
And the paedial gland stores melatonin and releases it
when there is loss of light.
So, if you have the habit of laying a bed
and staring at your phone or watching TV or something like that,
you aren't decreasing the light to the brain and stimulating the release of melatonin
from the paedial gland by doing that.
So, that's not, that's counterproductive.
So, that can be an issue.
So, make sure that you are going to bed when it gets dark out,
closing the shades, getting black out curtains
if you have to see it, that will help.
Another reason why you can, you might have issues falling asleep
is because you have excess glutamate in the brain.
So, glutamate is a neurotransmitter.
That's excitatory.
Stimulates the brain, wakes you up in the morning.
Glutamate is necessary.
So, it's not a bad thing, but excess glutamate is a problem.
So, look for glutamates in your diet.
Are you eating any processed foods that have glutamates in it?
That's what modus glutamate is.
That's a glutamate that stimulates excitatory transmission of the brain.
That's why they put it in food because it just wraps up your brain
and it goes, you go, whoa, this is really good.
And it's just because you have a brain stimulation when you eat that food
and it has nothing to do with taste.
So, it's a taste enhancer because it acts on the brain,
not because it's acting down to,
because it's actually enhancing the taste.
So, glutamates are caused, are produced in your body
through a breakdown of glutamate,
which is an amino acid that's found in any kind of protein.
So, excess glutamine can be bad for cancer patients
because glutamine can be a eater of cancer.
But glutamine will break down to glutamate,
especially if you have a lot of genetic defects on your GAD gene,
your GAD gene pathways.
So, you'll break down glutamine to glutamate quite quickly.
You'll have an excess of glutamate.
So, people that have OCD and anxiety and issues
and are ADD, ADHD typically have GAD defects
and they break down glutamine any protein that they eat into glutamate.
I have that, that's why it talks about it.
So, those people tend to be quick thinkers and things,
but sometimes they have more difficulty falling asleep.
So, you have to take precaution with that.
Don't cut out an approach before bedtime, things like that.
So, first, if that's the issue.
Another issue could be that I fall asleep,
but then I wake up and I can't go back to sleep again.
That is typically a cortisol issue.
Cortisol is a hormone that's released and made by the adrenal glands.
So, that's a totally different issue.
So, one test that's good to run is the Dutch complete test
because that does test for cortisol balance as well as other hormones.
That's something that we could look at and see where your cortisol balance is.
So, there's a lot of things to look at when a person says they have sleep issue.
There could be a lot of reasons because of that.
Not to mention just stress issues that you're thinking about too many things.
I mean, there's just tons of techniques that you could work on to try to decrease your stressful for a walk.
Before you go to bed that will help burn glutamate and glutamate and just call you out getting outside.
Before you go to bed, that will just help call you.
And we haven't begun to talk about light stimulation from computers.
I'm sitting here looking at a computer's computer screens any screen your television your telephone is vibrating at a frequency of 60 hertz.
Which is, you know, you know, a high high super high beta wave and a normal beta wave reading a wake and alert wave that your brain functions that is about 28 to 32 hertz.
So, you're stimulated your brain at a hyper wave.
You have to get down your brain has to get down to a theta wave, which is about 10 hertz in order for you to fall asleep.
So, if you are used to watching TV or looking at your phone, you're firing your brain at 60 hertz.
It's really hard to get it down to a theta wave for you to get to fall asleep.
So, one other thing is could you help you to THC is available in your area legally that can help you relax and fall asleep.
There's other reasons that you could be awake if you have paid issues things like that THC can be helpful for that.
So, really, it's such an individual thing.
In recent weeks, you've posted why it might be unwise to do a water fast only with cancer.
I tend to search your previous video. So, the reason why you don't want to do it.
So, the real thing is that you don't want to do a water fast greater than 24 or more hours.
And the reason is it increases IGF1 levels. So, a water fast of greater than 24 hours increases IGF1.
And that's the key. So, you don't want to increase IGF1. That's part of your growth factor, family.
Now, I have, we have patients and maybe people in a photo of this that have done a 12 day water fast, you know, and that they feel like that really helped turn their cancer around.
And so, I'm just saying this is a, this is a hard and fast rule. It's a general rule.
So, if a person wants to do fasting and they really feel led to do fasting, you know, you can do fasting.
It will increase IGF1 levels, but there is other benefits from that too. It will certainly decrease glucose levels.
So, there can be benefits to them. You can get just as, you know, nearly as good benefits from time restricted eating.
That's why we recommend that so heavily that you're only eating within a window of maybe, you know, cutting it down to three hours a day.
You know, I'm only eating between three and six in the afternoon, and that's all the time I'm really doing by feeding cycle and the rest of the time I'm fasting.
So, you could get just as good a benefits one could argue doing that, then doing a, you know, long 10 day fast or something like that. So consider that.
Is there a way to index topics on our weekly videos?
We have talked about this as a team many, many times.
It's, we actually have had someone work for us that have been cutting up the videos into smaller videos. That's where you see a lot of the smaller videos.
So, the course on the member site, I think the right page of the member site.
It's just very, very time consuming for us to do that and costly for us to do that.
We're trying to figure out just as working on some way with AI to be able to use AI to our advantage to help do some sort of video indexing. So, thank you for that.
I noticed the last few times I did the right foot bath program. I experienced extreme fatigue. We've heard this before that, you know, I got, I was just an absolutely liked after doing the foot bath had to lay down. I just couldn't do anything to rest the day.
I hope this is a good thing. Eating something helps to as often as I've been doing the intermittent past. I noticed this not by intention. That said, I often experience being tired with foot bath programs in general, but never this much.
It can be because you're hitting those higher frequencies. It can be because it's stimulating detoxification, and you're getting more of like a hurt cyber type reaction.
So, I think when you're doing frequencies and you notice that some sort of symptom pattern like this, I think that is a good thing as long as you can tolerate it.
Yes, I'm not vaccinated.
I'm at least with the MRI vaccine. Okay, that's good.
I did one round of ketruda and did just fine with minimal side effects. They decided to spread out my treatments and give me a double dose for round two.
This gave me extreme fatigue and Bell's paulsy. That's not good. So, Bell's paulsy is a,
is a cranial nerve seven facial nerve paulsy. Talk about that in just a second, which they say is temporary and the steroids seem to be helping.
I know you cannot tell me what to do either way. I'd love your opinion. But I'm not on the cell you right now. I can't tell you what to do with drugs. I know you have to do what your ecologist is asking you to do, but I'm not in favor of doing a double dose of any type of immunotherapy or chemotherapy.
I'm thinking that, oh, we'll just hit it double. We're going to skip one and do a double dose this time to be that is just done right danger. I don't, I just don't understand their thought process with that Bell's paulsy can happen when you have any type of inflammation.
This is cranial nerve seven. It comes out of the base of the skull and it's the facial nerve. So typically it'll be on one side, you'll get a complete drop of your face.
And it's, it's, oh, you know, typically, so if a person has Bell's paulsy and they had no precipitated issues like condition cancer and using a chemotherapy or a beautiful therapy that would have stimulated it typically Bell's paulsy.
It can be from a virus can be from, you know, stressful incident can be from attributed to cervical spine, bowel alignment, subluxation.
And one of the things that you need to do is stimulate that nerve because you do not want that nerve to die.
So I used to see Bell's paulsy patients in my office. You want to take a brush like a, like a figured out brush.
Of course, brush it to scrub your fingernails with and you want to push it under your skin and stimulate your skin. You need to stimulate that facial nerve. You can't let that facial nerve die.
The longer that you have Bell's paulsy, the more possible it is to fix Bell's paulsy. The person came in with Bell's paulsy that they just just noticed the effects of it just a few days or a week previous, we can always 100% get them back to normal.
If it was weeks or months, and they've been having this Bell's paulsy that it was made it more difficult because the nerve ends up.
The crossing, so you have to stimulate that nerve. So I used to teach people to stimulate that nerve stimulate that nerve using a brush using hot and cold water, getting adjusted. I would go to the chiropractor and get adjusted.
Make sure they do low-force technique given your condition. Do everything you can to stimulate that nerve.
And the reason why the steroid is helping is because it's anti-inflammatory. So you have inflammation of that nerve.
So you don't, you want to keep that nerve awake and alive.
I'm still on a feeding tube. So even crush pills are hard to get through. Are there any liquid supplements who'd suggest to help. I would definitely be on high dose curcumin with Bell's paulsy.
And that is the liquid liposomal curcuclear and you could use that.
That's a liquid.
If you, if you're mixing up your drinks like the greens and different things like that into a smoothie, you can water them down really good so that you can use that.
And any other liquid, so I'd like to give that some thought maybe we should have a conversation.
Would you suggest to take a break from hypervectin for longer than a few days. Not sure the lymph nodes in my deck.
Didn't know if they would need to catch up detoxing for any reason. Doctor doesn't seem too alarmed yet about them.
I don't know. I mean, I certainly know you know there's lots of people that have been taking hypervectin daily for the last four years.
And with no ill effects, I don't think you need to take a break from hypervectin.
Three separate hospital oncology departments have now recommended radiation and chemotherapy as a treatment combination that they would employ to fight my head and neck cancer, which has been classified as stage two.
So the radiologist considers it stage three due to the tumor sizes and the number of lymph nodes gets in two aboard beats tomorrow, but it's looking like they weekly.
A weekday radiation and high dose transplant weekly for seven weeks. If I do of another course of healing for these tumors, I would consider following that course, but I don't.
Remember, you are doing a lot of things and doing the things that you're doing, if the cancer is continuing to grow, you know, if you're doing everything you possibly can and the tumors continue to grow, then using, you know, a harsher course of care, maybe the right thing doesn't mean you have to do.
You know, everything that they're telling you to do, meeting the entire course of seven weeks, maybe you're only going to do two, three rounds of it and you feel like it's tricky to doing well and you, you know, feel like God is leading you to step back from that, then that's your choice.
You don't have to do the full course that they're saying and I would ask them to see, you know, is it progressing. That's the biggest thing.
I had to keep these small is it wouldn't put on the page. Is there any other alternative course you'd recommend the tumors are affecting my swallow it in speech and could affect my airway at some point.
We have other people I don't think they're on tonight's call that have this same type of cancer that have had issues in a fear of that it's going to affect their airway.
And some have chosen to do some radiation and some people and it helped and they're done with that and they did well through it.
So don't be afraid to do that. Just don't just make the decision based upon wisdom and based upon prayer.
And when I say wisdom, I mean, okay, that's just be wise about it. If it's progressing with everything you're doing, then maybe it is wise to at least consider prayerfully to do some of the quote unquote bigger guns that, you know, nobody wants to do but using that can knock it down with everything that you're doing.
If you must go this course or their things that you that I might request or negotiate to make it less harmful.
Not really for them. There's not going to be anything that they're going to be able to do to make it less harmful.
But you should have a conversation with me. We should talk about if there is anything that we want to do from a nutritional standpoint.
If you see like we do on our blog, you can see we do have if you search this for a chemo protocol. We have a chemo protocol on there.
And I think it's on the member site as well that it typically recommends that you, you know, go off of all your antioxidants for a period of time, 48 hours after the administration of chemo.
And then you go back on them and that you do a 24 hour fast prior to the administration of chemo. And of course, is as it means that if you're doing an IV chemo therapy.
So if you're doing chemo therapy at nine o'clock Monday morning, you start fasting at nine o'clock Sunday morning before chemo.
And then you would go off of any antioxidant nutrition.
And then you would help you identify what that is in your protocol. And you'd go off of that for 48 hours. So you wouldn't go back on and tell Wednesday sometime afternoon.
What steps should I take duried, minimize damage. So this is what we're talking about.
What steps should I take after radiation and chemo to facilitate detoxification.
And you'd go off of antioxidants for 48 hours because that's really when the chemo is doing its main work.
However, chemo is an oxidizing agent. So you don't want to negate the effects of chemo if you're going to do chemo.
And after you're done with radiation is also an oxidizing agent.
And when you're done with radiation and when you're done with after 48 hours of chemo, then you could hit hard antioxidants to pull that stuff out of your body.
I went to me get this winter and dropped unintentionally 20 pedals and five five hundred ten of trying to gain weight.
If I do chemo and radiation, what kind of nutritional strategies should I employ during the treatments to avoid losing any more weight.
And the feeding tube has been recommended. I would only recommend if you need the feeding tube.
Like you can't swallow there thinking because it's head neck cancer and the radiations, you might end up with such a painful throat that you won't want to eat.
And it's going to be hard to get you to eat because it's going to be painful.
And then you do not want to lose weight. You don't have weight to lose.
So you may have to consider getting a feeding tube to get the calories so you don't lose weight.
There has been quite some difficulty getting my new hospital record sent to you.
Have you received my biopsy? We did get something today. I haven't had chance to look at them.
So look at them. I and I, if you want to set up a time to go over them, I'm just called Marie.
Okay, I missed some questions here.
Do you know about Mark's book about Bethany Blue? What do you think about using Bethany Blue for Treaty cancer?
I haven't read his book. I've read some of Markola's information about Bethany Blue. I don't use his Bethany Blue.
Just he was one of his, I think, pieces of his book called for COVID.
And it makes sense for killing the viruses and bacteria. I have not heard about it using it for cancer.
Would Hashimoto's be an inflammatory?
Would Hashimoto's be an inflammatory with low dose? They'll track so this was suggested by my functional doctor that helps with my thyroid.
So Hashimoto disease is autoimmune disease of the thyroid.
And yes, any autoimmune disease is inflammatory or we'll have episodes of inflammation.
And yes, low dose don't truck so we could be very probably something that would be used for Hashimoto's. Yes.
I have a testicized prostate cancer. What do you think of prior oblation?
So yeah, using the prior oblation that is dependent on what you're talking about, what area, you know, is it just of the prostate.
We've had people that have done that with great success. So that's not anything that we do. So I can't give you a lot of comments on that.
And it's not something that we've had done, you know, we've had people do a lot. So, but I do know they've had a lot of success with it.
If I did information in the membership career and using hydrogen peroxide for oxygenation.
But it did not open and we start with one drop and go up food grade.
No, I am not a big fan of using hydrogen peroxide for cancer. And, and I do it to be pull up our site here, because I'm pretty sure I have a blog post on that.
Let me make sure it's live real quick. Yeah, I used your peroxide for cancer. So if you just search the blog, hydrogen peroxide for cancer, it's called hydrogen peroxide for cancer, not so fast.
And there's a YouTube video that is not linked. So that's what you're talking about.
So let me look, we actually had several YouTube videos taken down by YouTube because they were, I guess, some, I don't know, probably racist or something.
But yeah, they just went yesterday, they said, we pulled your YouTube video.
Okay, so I will fix that link for you real quick. And then you can look at it. So I'll just go back to that blog post in a couple minutes.
And then you will be able to see it. You're I fix it.
Okay, after by genetic test, I had a histamine issue.
You would suggest his sweet scavenger, I seem to get amped up on it. Yeah, we talked about that a couple times ago. That's why I stopped.
I know the story has hissed a clear and a DAO enzyme will this work is good also. And other is natural clear hiss.
This one has corsets of what this work. So there's a difference between clear histamine scavenger and natural clear hiss.
And the difference is just in the ingredients of the products, but the natural clear hissed and the histamine scavenger have the same principle there help be pull histamine out of the tissue.
That hista clear is a DAO enzyme. So the DAO enzyme is the purpose of that is to help break down histamine in the gut.
So the DAO enzyme isn't well absorbed.
So it really is just working in the gut.
And so it is not working beyond really the gut.
So if you have an issue beyond the gut, you're trying to pull his histamine out of the tissue, then you have to use clear histamine scavenger or histamine scavenger or the natural clear hiss.
And the reason why we have them both private labeled is because they have different ingredients in them. And some people do really well in the histamine scavenger and the natural clear hiss doesn't really do a lot. And some people do better on the natural clear hiss.
So it's got to try the try those and see the difference of those. That's really the only thing that you can do with that.
That DAO enzyme is for people who really have a lot of gut inflammation or and or their histamine issues are more related to inflammation in the gut because of many food sensitivities because of inflammatory bowel because of its histamines in their diet, that's the issue.
And then they would use the hista clear the DAO enzyme. So that's there are three different products.
Two of them the histamine scavenger and the natural clear hiss are working to pull histamine out of the tissue. Also there's another one called ABP1 assist helps pull histamine out of the tissue. There's three different products that can be good to help pull histamine out of the tissue.
It's the clear is the DAO enzyme that really helps break down histamine in the gut.
Okay, I have a Dutch test at home. I started back on an electrosol at the same time I received the test. So we decided to wait.
Let me know if this would be a good time to do the test. It's been five weeks or so other letters.
Yes, I'd say that's fine. Really, the electrosol really starts to work right away. So you could go that yeah, you could you could definitely run that.
I was talking to Alan Goldhead at true North and he asked.
Okay, I get the rest of the question. He asked.
I don't know yet.
If you could clarify that or was it the question that you asked before.
Okay, I did fix that link that YouTube link for hydrogen peroxide and cancer and you can watch that to get more details on why I will maybe not recommend it.
The tumor on my right breast stop bleeding with the cast oil on the bandage.
Now that's good news of that helps answer the question that actually weeks ago somebody had you about using cast oil on their breast tumor.
It then pulled out a fungus from the tumor you suggested sprayed hydrogen peroxide on the tumor under the cast oil.
Yeah, so that'd be different than taking cast hydro peroxide orally.
You're using it as a topical antiseptic. So that's where it's beneficial. So hydrogen peroxide is H2O2 readily gives off an extra oxygen to kill a bacteria or a virus or a pathogen.
And that's where hydrogen peroxide orally can be beneficial.
If you have like.
H by the word in the stomach or a bacterial infection in the stomach or in the garden.
But beyond that it could have other negative issues.
It could actually be a.
It oxidant that can damage cells and could be a cause of cancer.
So, but using it topically hydro peroxide is just how you use things.
This helped with the fungus, but then the bleeding started again. I'm trying to stabilize the bleeding so I can heal.
Other inside out any suggestions.
The other thing you can use is a topical antiseptic is colloidal silver.
That's another thing that you could use as a topical antiseptic.
You could also make your own with, with maybe an oil mix to it with an essential oil because you do you do what you use like something like a regular oil straight.
I mean, that would be burning horribly, but you could maybe mix it with a oil so you could use that.
The Tony's bell palsy. We're exactly on his face when he brush.
You could look up a graphic of the facial nerve on Google.
And you could kind of see that nerve and you want to brush along that nerve pathway.
It goes up to the temple area.
So you're brushing on the temple area and you could use your hands to scratch on it.
No, as you hear as we scratch it in my temple.
So I want people to be stimulating that nerve constantly, waky up that nerve, stimulating that nerve constantly.
Question about circulated tumor cells. I've been told they continue to be in your body for the duration of your life.
It's just a matter of monitoring. Are they in active cells, active cells stem cells.
I know the RGCC looks at them, but do cancer marker tests also track them.
So cancer marker tests do not track circulated tumor cells cancer markers themselves are different enzymes that give are given off by a lot of different cells.
Not just cancer cells. So that's why there's a normal range of
tumor markers. So the normal range of a CA 153 is on an old 030 035 meaning you could not have cancer and you could have a CA 153 of 15.
Well, why would that be because they're not specific to cancer other cells give those off to.
So circulated tumor cells are cancer stem cells, so they're not yet in a rapid replication phase.
It is disputable that you have circulated tumor cells the rest of your life.
I would argue that the chance of a person, you know, who had a diagnosis of cancer having circulated tumor cells that that are still alive, but not maybe not in rapid replication.
The body is quite possible and highly probable. So you should be always doing things to keep your cancer at bay.
I've heard too many stories of trying to throw along my 25 years of helping people with cancer of people thinking that they've they've cured their disease that they stop using the right for they stop doing it all the stuff that got them to the point of.
Well, you know, good spot with their cancer and then the cancer quote unquote comes back with the vengeance.
Well, it's because it never was totally gone there was circulated tumor cells that's why disagree and you've heard we say this a hundred times with a with an oncologist say you have no evidence of disease.
Well, that's actually a better terminology, which is a new term versus, you know, say that, you know, you're cured, you don't have cancer anymore or something like that.
You should always say that you're in a mission, you're doing well, keep doing what you're doing to keep yourself there. That's my point of view.
I'm thinking of taking artimistic or metastatic bone cancer.
I this is in the store what would be your opinion of which one to use.
I would use the artimistic and solo.
We used to use the artimistic and we have several artimistic and the artimistic and solo by research nutritional.
The white bottle with a yellow label, I think is a really clean product. It's called artimistic and solo.
I know others who have had cancer and have killed it and just do not know how to supplement to use. I would use that one.
Artimistic is, I haven't talked about artimistic for a long time.
It's a great product for bacteria as well.
As a matter of fact, it is kind of a bush that grows in like a shrub and it is native to Africa in multiple different areas.
Artimistic and what anua the name of the plant and it will kill all sorts of different diseases.
It's great for Lyme disease as well and it can be very helpful for cancer patients.
I watched a hydro-proxy video today.
Okay, good.
I was on Ivermected through another practitioner in this winter.
I tolerated it well and tell she doubled the dose and I broke out in a three week itchy rash that stopped and stopped the Ivermected.
Could this be good to be back on it for me, though a lower dose. Certainly it can be good.
Any day you can take too much, you can overwhelm your pathways.
If you broke out an itchy rash, I know somebody else and you're having issues with an itchy rash. I wouldn't like to know how that is going for you too.
It can be just because you're just kind of overwhelmed your body. You can, you know, sometimes you need to take a break from something.
Ivermected is the drug and you have to detoxify it so that could be the issue.
Oh, that was about fasting another person. Okay, good.
I will set up a call with ready to go over my situation this week. Thanks for help. Absolutely.
We know sugar from alcohol could treat cancer cells, but we know that red wine can be an antioxidant. Right. So we should all drink at least two bottles of wine a day.
But yeah, you can't argue the fact that a good clean wine can be beneficial.
You know, there's a story circulated around Instagram right now about somebody did a little short video on the guy who had terminal lung cancer that he was given just once to live and told him he had to go ahead and keep up therapy and stuff.
And he decided, forget it. I'm going to move back to my home town, which is a Greek island off the in the Mediterranean.
He moved back to that Greek island just to die. And he ended up living in other 20 years or something like that crazy, crazy story. I've talked about that story years ago.
I think I might even wrote about his story in my book. I don't remember. And he drank wide every day and just totally clean living all organic food, zero stress, all sorts of things contribute to one's healing. So everything with moderation is the right way to go.
And the words I have had success with the hydro peroxide, topically, with squamous skin skin cancer carefully with a Q tip and 35% food grade on the scam. And with 3% just straight out as well, surprised how well it worked. Yes.
Because because really it's actually working as an oxidizing agent. So it could kill topically like that.
But with it is that, you know, you think, oh, well, then it's going to work orally. I got to take it. It's going to go right to my cancer work as an oxidizing agent to my cancer. No, it's not. It's going to break down in your stomach.
And, you know, if you don't have cancer in your stomach or any bacteria to kill in your stomach, it's going to kill your gut flora.
It could be an oxidizing agent that could cause cancer in your stomach, your intestines and such. So, but if you're putting it directly on the cancer, that's totally different story. So it's like doing your own homemade chemotherapy in a sense.
All the tumors and effective lymph nodes are on the left side of my throat neck, nothing showing up anywhere else on the recent PET scan and CT scans the radiologist plans to radiate my right side as well as far reaching around the tumors, etc.
What I asked why and could you keep it more localized. He said no, that it would be a disservice to me and he would not.
If I did choose to cut the treatments short, as you just recommended, as you just mentioned, he might be doing other areas before necessary areas. I have no say in it at first.
This is why you might need to ask around and talk to a radiologist or radiology oncologist who will work with you and do what you want to do.
And he or she may actually give you some valid reasons why they want to do it a different way.
But more often than not, they want to do it a certain way because that's what's dictated to them. And if they do it a different way, the way that you may want it to do it, they make more sense, like why don't you just do the spots that have the cancer.
Well, then they're liable for not following protocol and if they don't follow protocol and you have a World Cup, you could sue them.
You know, most of the stuff that's done in the practice of medicine today is avoiding a lawsuit.
And how they avoid assault lawsuit is, you know, if they give you chemotherapy and the chemotherapy kills you, you can't sue them.
You can't sue them being one of the dead, but you can't sue them because that's what was standard procedure.
So they could kill a person using standard procedure, aka COVID, and you can't sue them because it was considered standard procedure.
But if they do something out of standard procedure and bad things happen and you sue them, well, then they could be liable. So as long as they, you know, kill you from a legal standpoint, then you can't do anything.
Very sad, but this is the situation that we live in.
I have not heard about a missing before. Could it be good for me as well. Well, a lot of things could be good for everybody. So you don't want to just be throwing everything yet. The wall either. So, um, that did test for you, but, um, you don't want to be taking too many things.
You know, don't just trust what I say. You need to be praying about your situation. What you should be doing it.
There's wisdom in the multitude of counselors and certainly the counselor of the Holy Spirit work in your heart. That's the greatest wisdom that you want to listen to.
So be seeking a relationship with him more than anything else so that you can hear his still quiet voice telling you what to do and leading you in a certain way.
June is by two year diagnosis anniversary, breast cancer, one B, no conventional therapies, no symptoms, also no idea if I'm getting better since I can still feel the tumor.
Hate the idea of this waiting for symptoms and tasks. It's I need to know if I'm beating this or not.
Thinking of doing a pet scan to see if the tumor, maybe if I'm on it, or maybe see the test is this earlier. I think there's anything wrong with doing that.
I'll be I've always said don't do an invasive test just to satisfy your curiosity, but if you feel like God is leading you to do it, you haven't done any invasive test meeting that okay, that's the radiation.
But hey, I haven't done any other pet scans or CT scans. This would be my first.
And you feel led to do it by all means doing it. It's the accumulation of such radiation than that is that our damaging to us not just doing wonders.
I have a squirting hydro peroxide on the open to where my throat should I use 30 it's 35% instead.
35% is pretty costing. So I don't know that I would do that. No, because then you are swallowing it to so I would not do that.
I enjoyed late I did you see my answer.
See answer my gross question if so I can wait I did answer all your questions that I believe you got in with the 10 minutes of this call starting.
I have only had one MRI and didn't detox get Lydia well, well, there's not going to be any Galileo is totally different. So, you know, I wouldn't be like, oh, I don't want to do a pet scan because I had a reaction to the Galileo in a MRI.
That is that you know doesn't mean that you're going to have a reaction to anything with that scan. So, I had a lady and this is totally different.
All the wax that people could have issues with.
All right, thanks for being on the call.
We've gone an hour here. So I think we'll end it here.
You know that I prayed for all of you and we'll get this up right away. So if you had to answer, get it late.
Then you can listen to it. All of my MRIs have been without getting ready. I'm going to show it enough to be clear.
It really depends on the oncologist and radiologist.
Some will not do what they just won't see it as well. Some today on the tour, it's been what they're looking for. They're happy with what they can see.
So, you certainly do see more with a contrast.
So, but they're skilled. They can the radiologists can see without a dispel.
All right. Thank you guys much. I love you all the next week.